Okay, Bruce says, what are your thoughts on going into a city that someone from our groups already running ads in using concrete as example, most of us that are in concrete look in the same area is probably due to winter rapidly approaching.
Okay, so it's up to you, man.
There's probably room for for people for multiple people to get deals. But if it was me. I think there's a big difference and I don't want you to get to get confused if I'm doing a homework on a city.
And I see a lead generation site. Okay. And the city still looks wide open, I don't see any ads, whatever or I don't see any ads from the lead generator. To me that's just another competitor.
Okay, I don't think that market saturated whatever.
Now, if I go in and I'm looking at Las Vegas concrete and I see that somebody literally has a landing page that looks just like ours they have ads that the same ad copy.
I may want to just consider going on to the next city. Okay.
Now, you could also reach out to that person and say hey what do you think about doing a deal together. So there's, there's different ways you can look at it but for me.
I mean, I probably would not.
If it's somebody from this group I probably would not. Okay, just my two cents. There's too many cities, there's too many niches.
Go look at that same city go look at that installation go look at it in artificial grass go look at it in, you know, another niche that that that we know works.